hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of Rick and Morty's season 3 episode 2
Rick man seeing the stone Louie Rick and
Morty is back I've been dying for this
ever since the season 3 premiere was
released early back in April actually go
check out my breakdown of that and look
I know it can be a little weird to
overanalyze comedy but really Justin
roiland and Dan Harmon's animation is so
layered with subtle humor that pointed
out all the sneaky ways they made the
show even funnier is kind of fun in its
own right so I'm gonna help you avoid
being a red grin grumble every time the
show makes that deep cut cool cool let's
get started with the opening images
right away as Rick is rambling about the
meaninglessness of life notice I was
eyes drift outward almost as if he's
reflecting on his own existential dread
remember he's still probably recovering
from that introspective journey he took
when he incarcerated himself and then
when he manufactured a fake origin story
to escape but it turns out no as always
Rick isn't feeling he's insulting
someone else and he's staring directly
at recently divorced Jerry and I love
all the little ways this episode points
out how pathetic Jerry is like notice
how he's wearing these same dumb Titanic
hat from Rick see business almost like
you can't afford to buy a new hat also
the you tow truck that he's using to
move out is the same brand of moving
truck bed Jerry tried to use to move
Rick out into a nursing home in the very
first episode but now he's getting moved
out with it and your mom's lawyer says
if I can get enough in the settlement he
can help me sue for full custody yeah
Jerry is bragging about how one he has
no lawyer of his own and two he's about
to get screwed out of any settlement
money that he wins in fact all of nature
has turned against Jerry the wind in the
voice of Justin roiland actually
whispers this at him what and that
happens both in this scene and later on
in the post-credits scene where a wolf
gets nourishment by chewing up his
unemployment cheque also I just like the
implication the final line of this
episode is that what they offer with
Jerry not knowing what prostitutes are
because the loves Beth so much that he
would never even fathom cheating on her
okay let's move on to the opening
credits now season 3 actually added some
new clips to this sequence first there's
a butt-faced Morty who's looking at rub
hub which is a parody of pornhub he's
watching a video with a but with faces
when a buttface beth walks in and notice
how the frame actually cuts off right
where Morty's poster normally is
presumably that woman would have had to
a butt face as well there's also a few
shots that I presume are from upcoming
episodes this season two summers on a
mission and then various Morty's
sneaking out of what looks like a Morty
Academy and then this super gruesome
shot of giant piano hammer smashing
skulls we actually already broke down
some of these images in our trailer
break down and feel free to watch it on
mute if Erickson's voice drives you
crazy now I really love this shot of
Rick buying these life-sized action
figure Morty's eats with their own
weapon now it sets aside this one was a
bat with nails sticking out of it and
instead he picks up this one with the
sword from legends of Zelda I also like
how the sign says everyday low prices
everyday self-esteem and then in the
foreground there's a bin of plumb busses
on sale okay moving on to this chase in
the wasteland dimension and there are a
ton of Mad Max references in this
episode so let's run through them
quickly
this short shotgun is Max's weapon and
road warrior then there's this guy who
says he is clearly inspired by immortan
joe there's also this shoulder mounted
baby just like this little guy from fury
road and then of course later Rick calls
the gladiator arena the Thunderdome even
though the death stalkers have their own
stupid name for at the Blood dome then
there's this woman with milk pumps from
her brass actually collects the milk and
baby bottles this is just like immortan
joe's mother's milk women also this guy
sprays pink paint on his face just like
the war boys spraying silver paint on
their faces in fury road another a
Deathstalker says this line which is a
reference to the war boys catchphrase
and then in summers outfit later in the
episode is inspired by Tina Turner's
costume and Beyond Thunderdome
and then finally her neighbor reveals
her pregnancy with this line one man
entered one man comes out at nine months
which of course is a nod to the famous
Thunderdome chant ok the character of
hemorrhage is voiced by joel mchale who
played Jeff Winger on Dan Harmon's
previous show community actually later
when summer hooks up with him on the
table I feel like that's a nod to when
jeff infamously hooked up with Britta on
the table in the study room then Rick
notices the Deaf stalkers massive chunk
of isotope 322 which gives this episode
its title Rick
and seeing the stone now that is taken
from the movie Romancing the Stone where
kathleen turner and michael douglas
sought after another massive green stone
this emerald called the core zone in
columbia now as we move on to the death
stalkers camp i love how much detail
went into the animation of these shots
an animator said they wanted each
Deathstalker to look different with no
duplicate characters and in addition to
Mad Max they use all kinds of influences
to create them 90s punk and S&M bondage
so I want to actually run through all
the specific weird stuff that I spotted
there's hemorrhages driver who shows up
later this Deathstalker is wearing this
World War One era German helmet with a
spike on top and what the gas mask
account looks like he's going for a
Darth Vader look then there's this
passed out woman with graffiti drawn all
over her body there's a penis drawn on
her face and someone was here written on
her arm there's this Deathstalker with a
cast mask connected to his crotch I
guess he likes the smell then there's
just as guys with random crap on them
there's one guy's a lampshade on his
head another has a medical neck brace
and then this one warrior is traffic
themed apparently he has a road cone
helmet and a stop sign shield and he
carries an exhaust pipe as a weapon I
also like how this old ice-cream truck
has been transformed into a human meat
truck and then later there's a woman who
uses a bowling ball as a weapon
just like Janeane Garofalo scare achter
and mystery men okay moving on let's
talk about one of my favorite moments
this episode you just put it up for
decoration uh you mean the blood dome
save it for the semantics Doh me be
white okay so even ye Charlotte's Web
author also wrote a book called The
Elements of Style which is kind of the
famous guide for grammar and semantics
and this episode is actually very
consistent with the death stalkers
fixation with correct language notice
this callback later from hemorrhage did
the boom-boom' blow up all your birdie
word books in dictionaries okay next up
Rick uses this muscle memory serum to
give Morty this giant arm which has the
name arm a--they it has its own sentence
from literal muscle memories this is
actually an example of the evil hand
trope that has really shown up in a lot
of movies and TV shows famously was used
in dr. Strangelove and Evil Dead 2 was
also in the movie body parts also in
case you were wondering the show
announced that the game pocket Morty's
will be updated with new Morty's as they
come out on the show
and giant arm Morty is now Morty you can
catch in the game along with wasteland
Morty and Android Morty now there are a
few other boys cameos in this episode
first the Blood dome announcer eli is
voiced by tony hale it's kind of hard to
tell because it sounds like he's doing
his best justin roiland impression also
the Viking invader that are methey
remembers from his past and gets revenge
upon he is voiced by John DiMaggio he's
the voice of bender from Futurama and
then we get a few more Easter eggs when
summer joins hemorrhage and wasteland
Seattle first notice how they talk here
after the boom boom some adapted to the
new truth and some chose to huddle near
the boom hijos clinging to the lie of
the before fortune this actually sounds
a lot like the language from when we saw
Cloud Atlas on Rick and Morty the
alternate dimension version of Jerry
who's a famous actor actually appeared
in this movie in Rick's team in its
episode I'm small true true different
beat you can also barely make out an
Atari and Bart Simpson's shirt on these
humanoids and speaking of shirts later
this episode hemorrhage where is another
shirt that you might remember from the
90s is big Johnson brand now when our
methey goes on this murder spree in the
blood dome notice how Morty starts to
really get into it he's venting his
bottled up anger now we see Morty
violently snapped like this before
specifically in the look who's purging
now episode
yeah Morty is clearly someone who wants
to avoid violence as much as possible
but yeah when he can't it definitely
helped some processes anxiety okay
jumping ahead this episode there's a few
jokes that I really liked in the scene
when summer connects with hemorrage
first when he removes his bucket to
reveal his awkward mustache summer says
this a metal bucket is on a certain
level a kind of mustache in that it's a
specific facial accessory so it's kind
of like do you guys have the phrase hat
on a hat so hat on a hat is a term with
a few meetings like it's sometimes used
in football but in this case it's a
comedy writers term roiland and Harmons
snuck in one of these into the season
premiere - if you remember with the rule
of threes comedy comes in
and I know I'm over explaining this but
putting a hat on a hat basically means
overwriting a joke but that is what
summer is saying hemorrhage is doing
here using a literal hat on a hat to
double accessorize his head also at the
beginning of the scene hemorrhage says
that the leash people in their society
are kind of like interns so I love how
the end of the scene pays that off
moving on one of the fun subplots of
this episode was Rick building Android
versions of Morty in summer and yeah
there are definitely some Westworld
parallels here summer by 15% an
increased dynamic movement by three am i
right this sounds a lot like Rick is
adjusting a West world style attribute
matrix and then later when Android Morty
rants about wanting consciousness trying
to bypass the override his shutdown and
reset is very similar to win the hosts
of West world glitch and reset I also
like when Rick says this line is these
shuts down summer read in the morning
you just became my backup toaster this
is a more subtle callback to the robot
that Rick designed for the sole purpose
of passing the butter for his breakfast
you pass butter ok jumping ahead again
in the episode summers break up with
hemorrhage actually mirrors Beth's
separation from Jerry last episode
emerge and I are taking some time apart
oh no Tom no Jerry's going to spend some
time divorce oh I'm sorry to hear that
sweetie
I think the point of this parallel is to
help summer deal with her parents
divorce by fast tracking her through
married life so yeah that's why we see
Rick snatchy in this last chunk of
isotope 322 out of hemorrhages generator
the only people he's here to help are
his grandkids and yeah by the way this
one chunk was powering the entire grid
of the death stalkers notice how earlier
all the power was emitting from
hemorrhages house so basically Rick just
reverted this society back into a
wasteland
I like this episode a lot but not
everyone did online so what were your
thoughts also what was your favorite
joke in this episode let me know down in
the comments you can also tweet your
thoughts directly to me at Ieva or new
rockstars at new rockstars and we're
gonna try to keep these breakdowns
coming throughout the season nope
says we're super busy covering all kinds
of stuff here on this channel but you
can help us by liking this video and
sharing it specifically by sharing a
link to this YouTube video on Twitter
and of course subscribing to new rock
stars
you can also help us expand our
operation and make more videos by
contributing to us on patreon big thanks
to all our current donors especially
Kelly hopper alright thanks for watching
bye oh yeah this is swifty [ __ ] on the
floor
[Music]